michigan's first gay attorney general
says there should be a drag queen for
every school
a michigan attorney general is facing
criticism after she suggested that there
should be a drag queen for every school
this is attorney general dana nessel is
her name nestle's the first openly gay
person voted into statewide office in
michigan
drag queens make everything better drag
queens are fun she said
who wrote that for her does that not
sound weird who talks like that
she's quoted by the detroit news and
then she says a drag queen for every
school which she told this reporter
and the reporter went on to tweet that
nestle admitted her comment had not been
poll tested you don't say
you don't say that that hadn't been poll
tested maybe if it had been poll tested
she wouldn't have said it because that's
not going to be a popular statement
i don't care republican democrat
you have a family you're thinking about
things are getting crazy real crazy and
real fast
this was the response by matt diperno
the republican candidate for attorney
general in that state
great response
students in the third grade are behind
on their reading
our test scores are some of the worst in
the country thanks to these disastrous
coveted lockdowns and she calls for drag
shows for kindergartners
fantastic response didn't go for a
personal attack didn't call her a dummy
that was pretty dumb what she said
but
didn't do any of that just said
these are your priorities and i think
that's an important point we just talked
about you know what are the strengths of
the democrat party where are they
where are their priorities
the country is in many ways falling
apart at the seams i'm not going to
sugarcoat that people can't afford to
pay for gas
okay they can't afford to put gas in
their car you have kids that are so far
behind in school
because of these lockdown policies and
because of these remote learning
policies
these kids are so far behind that
teachers are struggling now to how do we
catch them up there were kids that had
disabilities
that couldn't learn with masks on
i mean there are big things that happen
in families this year there were parents
one parent how to you know quit a job
and stay home and deal with all this
remote learning
there was income that was lost
in households
parents are upset they want answers they
don't understand what was going on with
the school closures when they found out
that those talking points were being oh
the teachers union and the cdc working
together on talking points maybe that
wasn't so popular for parents who were
struggling at home to put food on the
table you don't say
this is the kind of answer that needs to
be given
where are your priorities
you're talking about putting drag queens
in schools for storytelling when people
are still trying to figure out how to
pay their bills you know how many
families right now in the country are
living paycheck to paycheck
i come from a family that was like that
for a while it was a struggle you had to
figure out okay can we take a vacation
this year okay let's save our money for
that vacation my parents saved all of
their money to be able to put me in the
best school on staten island because
they felt like education was the key to
success a lot of sacrifice a lot of
blood sweat and tears went into those
sacrifices there are families like that
all around the country you think they
want to hear you prioritizing oh let's
bring a drag queen and do makeup lessons
at school no they don't
they don't
so this is a phenomenal answer the
reason i juxtapose these stories is
because the hillary clinton story
hillary clinton is where the democrat
party was
that's like you know obama saying
oh we're gonna you know mandate everyone
who has everyone to have health
insurance
that was democrats it was big government
but it was sane big government
now it's
let's put a drag queen in every school
and you have to get a mandatory
experimental vaccine or you're going to
lose your job
slippery slope
real slippery again
okay
also important to note there's a lot of
phonies in this game
so i don't know i don't know i sit here
and i think sometimes you know do these
politicians really stand for what they
say they stand for i don't know i don't
i distrust politicians by nature
so you gotta dig deep on these things
sometimes when you vote you gotta figure
out
how do you separate the fact from the
fiction how do you separate the phones
from the non-phones that's why i brought
out bernie i disagree with bernie on
almost everything i don't think he's a
phony
hillary clinton is a phony she says what
needs to be said i think aoc is a phony
says what needs to be said sift through
the phonies if you like the short clip
you can catch another one here or you
can catch the full episode right here
[Music]